when we discuss various atrocities and
violent tragedies that have occurred
across history one of the most common
topic that comes up is that of the
crusades now most of these crusades at
least the most famous ones were aimed at
taking back areas that had been
conquered by the muslims especially the
holy city of jerusalem but another one
of the most major crusades in the middle
ages was one that took place within
european christendom itself
the so-called albigensian crusade was an
attempt by the catholic church to root
out what they saw as a dangerous heresy
that had erupted in southern france and
northern italy the supposed heretics at
least if we are to believe the
catholic chroniclers uh held beliefs
that were sometimes very different
indeed sometimes very
dimetrically opposite to the mainstream
doctrines of the catholic church and
which according some scholars may have
had connections to various religious
movements of antiquity like the gnostics
and the manichaeans this fascinating
group in medieval western europe has
become known as the cathars
[Laughter]
[Applause]
we're back in medieval europe a
tumultuous time to say the least as
we've seen in previous episodes a lot is
taking place at this time
a lot of violence of course as the
catholic church becomes increasingly
interested in clamping down on perceived
threats both politically and religiously
but paradoxically this is also a time of
intellectual flourishing
contrary to popular belief medieval
europe gave us some of the most
significant philosophers and thinkers in
history many of whom were hugely
original and presented daring ideas
and in spite of the church's
all-encompassing authority in all
matters religion we still see various
religious movements appear at this time
now one of the most fascinating and
noteworthy of these are the so-called
cathars who posed perhaps the biggest
threat to catholic authority at the time
the cathars flourished in western europe
from the second half of the 12th century
to the first half of the 14th especially
in the region known as longadoc which is
located primarily in southern france
teaching a doctrine of strict dualism
and anti-materialism
the cathodes were harshly condemned by
the catholics as demonic heretics
opposed to the central tenets of
christian beliefs and were for this
reason wiped out in the albigensian
crusade and the inquisitions that were
connected to it and thus even before we
start the discussion itself we've
already run into our first problem
you know the old saying history is told
by the victors and the victors in this
case was undoubtedly the catholic church
and when people try to wipe out a heresy
they tend to
like really wipe it out leaving no
well as little evidence
both in terms of people but also in
writings and material evidence as
possible so when we try to retell and
understand the doctrines and the history
of these so-called cathodes we don't
have much in the way of firsthand
material to rely on from the catheters
themselves that is in other words a lot
of the material that we have to rely on
come directly from the catholic church
or from the crusaders themselves who
were obviously the great enemies of the
cathers the people who despised them so
as is my usual refrain we should
approach these kinds of sources
skeptically and carefully but if we at
least assume that a lot of what is said
in these accounts are true which they
are in a lot of cases in these kinds of
situations despite possible biases we
can get some basic idea about what these
catheters were supposed to believe and
who they were they seemed to have been a
group that was highly critical of the
catholic church and consider a lot of
the church's beliefs and rituals and
practices to be misguided and even
satanic in some cases
the cathars appeared to have been very
strict duelists so they had a dualistic
world view where the material world was
actually created by the devil himself
the origins of this movement is
contested among scholars and historians
some have wanted to connect its
doctrines with earlier famous dualistic
movements of antiquity like the gnostics
and the manichaeans who held ideas quite
similar
according to this view we can see a
continuous tradition carried on from the
gnostics in the earliest years of
christianity which later is supposed to
have spread into other parts of europe
but many other scholars aren't convinced
and instead view the dualistic movement
of medieval europe as unique and
independent despite the similarities
what seems somewhat clear to a lot of
historians is that western european
catheterism in particular is connected
to an earlier movement known as the bogo
mills which emerged in the 10th century
in eastern europe primarily in bulgaria
macedonia serbia and eventually central
locations like constantinople
the bogo meals were also dualists whose
ideas correspond to a great degree to
the later cathars in france and there is
likely to be a continuity between the
two
this
cathar movement seems to have appeared
for the first time or they appear on the
historical record in the mid 12th
century although bogomi doctrines may
have spread there even earlier than that
the beliefs of the cathars are
absolutely fascinating and may appear
shocking to christians of a mainstream
bent
as mentioned earlier the central aspect
of this teaching is dualism
similar to groups like the gnostics they
taught that there are two worlds a
divine immaterial world of spirit
created by the good god and the material
world that we live in which has been
created by the devil himself and is thus
seen as a very dirty and evil prison to
be escaped
originally the bogomiles and early
cathodes appears to have held what
scholar malcolm barber calls a more
moderate dualism where god remains the
sole absolute power and creator
including of the devil who in turn has
created the material world
we can see this narrative in one of the
known works of the bogomides the
so-called secret supper which was also
imported to the cathode community
in a work by malcolm barber it is
described as such quote passing through
all these layers he in other words satan
began to subvert the angel's allegiance
by offering them a lower scale of
obligations than thy old god
cast out by god for his treachery satan
took a third of the angels with him but
could find no peace in the firmament so
he presented himself as a sinner who had
repented
the lord was moved with pity for him and
gave him peace to do what he would until
the seventh day meaning by this the
seventh age of the world
it was during that time that satan
created the earth and the living things
within it including man formed from clay
made to serve him the angels that satan
brought with him from heaven were forced
to reside in these human bodies thus
being trapped to serve him until they
could escape now we can see clear
parallels to gnosticism here which also
taught that an ignorant demiurge called
the aldebarath had created the material
world and the human body
in the above narrative satan has created
the universe we know but he himself was
subordinate to god hence we refer to
this as a moderate dualism it appears
however that sometime in the 12th
century a more absolute dualism had
taken root in the cathode community in
this absolute dualism good and evil
represented by god and the devil are
instead both eternal forces that have
always existed and have nothing to do
with each other
god has created and rules over the
spiritual realm and satan the material
and they appear to have an equal
standing in some sense this kind of
absolute dualism we can find in another
treatise known as the book of the two
principles probably written later on in
the 1240s in light of this dualistic
core the cathars interpreted many other
christian doctrines in similarly unique
ways
similar to the gnostics they rejected
most of the old testament or hebrew
bible and its prophets as proponents of
satan
they simply couldn't accept the idea
that the god described in the old
testament who orders the destruction and
massacre of various groups of people to
be the true good god described in the
new testament
instead it must be the evil creator
satan who is described here
instead they rely only on the gospels
and other books of the new testament as
sources as well as some few books from
the old testament or hebrew bible
because they see the material world and
body in such a negative light it is
perhaps not surprising that they also
adamantly deny the human nature of jesus
he only appeared to take on a human body
but was really only a spiritual being he
was never born of the virgin he never
hungered or thirsted indeed he was never
truly crucified or died on the cross but
only appeared to do so
the role of jesus is thus very different
to the catholics he was sent by the true
god to help mankind but he did so by
establishing the initiatory church which
the catholics saw themselves as taking
part in and whose job it was to help the
spiritual parts of human beings escape
from the evil prison of the body and
return to heaven from which we came you
can kind of see why the catholic church
would be so upset
with these doctrines they completely
rejected the catholic church they saw
its beliefs its
some of its primary doctrines and
rituals to be completely false
the symbol of the cross was a false idol
to be rejected the eucharist and baptism
through water were evil innovations and
the very foundational ideas about god
and jesus and who they were were
fundamentally wrong according to the
catholics in any case with this
dualistic outlook in mind the catholics
appear to have been able to create some
pretty solid structures of their own
some historians even talk about a
catholic church which had established
itself to some degree in the longadoc
region of southern france this supposed
church had a clergy and a structural
hierarchy in which different people had
different roles
at the top of this hierarchy was the
bishop followed by the elder son then
the younger son and lastly the deacon
now the name for a more ordinary
semi-lay person who nonetheless was
initiated as an adept in the cathode
teachings was called a perfecti
and regular lay people connected to the
faith were simply referred to as good
christians
quite a complex structure as you can
tell which suggests that the cathodes
may have been quite established as a
movement as is usually the case the
practices and obligations of the
catheters could differ depending on
where in this hierarchy you stood but in
general it can be very difficult to try
to reconstruct the practices that the
catharsis would
perform here we also had to rely on
hostile sources
one of my main sources for the cathodes
generally is a chronicler and cistercian
monk called peter of valdez cerne who is
definitely not a fan
nonetheless he describes the cathode
ethics and practice thus called
the perfected heretics where a black
robe claimed falsely to practice
chastity and renounced meat eggs and
cheese
they wished to appear that they were not
liars although they lied especially
about god almost unseasonally
they believed that they could be saved
without restitution of what they had
stolen and without confession and
pentions so long as they were able to
recite the lord's prayer and ensure a
laying on of hands by their masters in
the final moments of their lives as hard
as it may be to find morsels of truth in
such hostile accounts peter does here
allude to some practices that are very
commonly attributed to the catheters
including by other
less emotional accounts including that
the catheters lived a life of chastity
so that they had a rather negative
stance towards sexual relations
as well as certain dietary restrictions
primarily a kind of vegetarianism where
they would only consume fish for the
most part but would deny themselves the
meat
cheese and eggs and among other things
the perfecti also appears to have taken
part in some rather rigorous fasts for
three days a week where they would only
eat water and bread as well as more
longer fast for 40 days at a time now
most of these practices are somehow
connected to their very negative stance
towards the material body generally sex
was seen as something very dirty and
sinful even when performed between
husband and wife not only did it satisfy
the lusts of the physical body but also
served as a means of creating new
material life which wasn't to be
preferred
we find here similarities with the
strictly dualistic religion of
manichaeism which had a similarly
negative stance on all things material
while regular catheters still had
children of course since the community
survived and was passed down through
generations but there seems to have
always been a kind of uneasy attitude
towards procreation which is well
expressed in a tragic comic account when
a catholic woman tells her pregnant
friend that she should quote ask god to
free her from the demon which she had in
her belly
the human being sought to be freed from
the material world and that is the
creation of satan through being
initiated into the catholic church and
to practice
catholism basically
the souls of humans were thought to
reincarnate into new bodies until this
release is achieved
naturally then they deny the common
doctrine of the physical resurrection of
the dead at the end of time as well as
the day of judgment
instead much like the manichaeans they
believe that in the end times the
creation of light which resides in the
material prison will be separated from
evil and the two worlds will be distinct
again and to be initiated into the
cathode church meant that you took part
in what is perhaps the most important
and characteristic ritual or practice of
this movement known as the consolamentum
this was a kind of initiatory ritual
similar in role to the catholic baptism
but very different in its particulars
indeed the catholics in this context
very much criticizes the mainstream
practice of baptism through water which
the catholics and other
christians took part in partly because
it is performed on infants who don't
grasp the significance of the ritual and
can't choose to become initiated but
also because water is after all material
and thus dirty it's the creation of the
devil after all instead the
consolamentum sometimes known as the
quote baptism of the spirit is a complex
ritual of several stages the person who
was to be initiated first went through a
long period of preparation before the
ritual itself took place
then the ceremony included several
invocations and prayers including a
variant of the lord's prayer and finally
a quote laying on of hands by good men
so literally several initiates into the
church would simultaneously put their
hands on the head of the person and
formally initiate him
and after this the initiate would also
be taught how to give the consolamentum
himself especially to the sick and dying
this practice is probably what peter
valdez serenay was referring to at the
end of that earlier very critical quote
and i'll quote again they believed that
they could be saved without restitution
of what they had stolen and without
confession and pentions so long as they
were able to recite the lord's prayer
and ensure a laying on of hands by their
masters in the final moments of their
lives what he's referring to here is the
idea that when the person is given the
consolamentum that is initiated all his
previous sins are basically abolished
and he is sort of purified his soul is
completely purified that doesn't
mean that he can't sin in the future of
course and he may have to
be reinitiated as a result but this is
the basic idea that when someone is
given the console lamentum their sins
are basically forgiven you could say and
this is also connected to another very
important aspect of this ritual
tradition which is also what peter
refers to in his quote which is the idea
that old people or people who are dying
generally were given the consolamentum
by cathar priests
as a way to
help the dying person by giving him this
ritual this initiation at the end of his
life he could face his own death on the
best terms since he had just been given
this very sacred rite which had at least
to some degree absorbed him of previous
sins and purified him to some degree by
becoming a catholic initiate all this
shows that the cathars appeared to have
been a very unique and fascinating
movement and part of medieval france and
medieval europe which differed quite
dramatically in some ways from
mainstream christianity it's hard to say
for sure just how widespread and
influential this movement had become but
many sources suggest that they had
gained the support of various local
lords and leaders in southern france at
the time who may have helped them by
sheltering them giving them places to
stay and food and and so on which
created a kind of network an
infrastructure in which this cather
community could thrive at least to some
degree in the 12th and early 13th
century cities such as toulouse and
others in the longadoc region appears to
have housed a at least a significant
number of cathodes even if they probably
never were the majority the catholic
church had been very uneasy about the
catholic movement for a while there were
debates that took place between catholic
representatives and catholics and
attempts here and there to try to
counteract their spread but in the early
13th century they had had enough
after a papal delegate was apparently
assassinated by people connected to the
catheters while on a mission in france
in 1208 pope innocent iii decided to
initiate more drastic measures
this was the start of the albigensian
crusade
from 1209 and for about the next 20
years the catholic crusaders went on a
violent campaign to destroy the cathodes
once and for all many cities associated
with cathode activity became under siege
catheters themselves as well as their
supporters were often captured and
burned alive burned to death and
assassinated this included many
civilians as the massacres didn't always
discriminate all that much to the point
that some historians want to refer to
this event as a full-blown genocide in a
famous story about the massacre of
bezier the crusader are now a malrik
assads have been asked how to
distinguish between catholics and
catholics when they sort of entered the
city to which he called the replied
quote kill them all god will know his
own
there's quite a good possibility that he
never actually said this and that this
is a dramatization of the events but it
sort of captures the spirits of these
crusades a lot of people were killed
including civilians and the crusaders
didn't always really distinguish between
who was who in the course of the
albigensian crusade which officially
ended in 1229
the crusaders managed to conquer and
subjugate many cities and regions
associated with cathode activity as well
as leaders who were suspected of having
housed catheters or supported
catheterism in some way but in reality
this was only a minority many places of
catholic activity were still outside of
their control even by the end of the
crusade but nonetheless the crusade had
begun the process which led to their
decline and the eventual disappearance
completely of the catholic community
after the crusade ended the pope and his
church would continue the fight by
sending inquisitors continuously into
regions associated with cathode activity
a process that continued for most of the
13th century by the middle of the
century the infrastructure that
supported the cather movement had
completely been dismantled which left
its adherence without an organization
and often forced to be on the run
barbara writes quote by the mid-1240s
the cathers of longadoc were oppressed
from three sides by the weight of royal
military and bureaucratic power by the
loss of their traditional secular
supporters and by the determined and
systematic prosecutions of the
inquisitors
and that court catherism had been driven
down the social scale leaving few noble
supporters while most of its ministers
had been captured or had fled to
lombardy bernard akier even if he had
had the capability was in no position to
study the literature of his faith or to
convey such learning to others instead
he functioned only in small and
uncoordinated gatherings of believers or
in meetings with individuals
and this development continued for the
rest of the century with the exception
of a brief revival led by the autie
brothers peter and william who were
captured and executed in 1309 and 1310
the catholics never really recovered
from the persecution to the point that
by the mid 14th century we find little
record of their existence at all the
catholic church through their crusades
and the inquisitors had managed it seems
to quell this movement and restore their
own power in regions that had been
influenced by catholic ideas previously
and you might think that the narrative
is over here but there's a twist to this
story
in fact the cathars as we understand
them
may have never actually existed
indeed many historians studying the
subject today
argue that the idea of a unified
heretical movement in longidoc is more
of a construction by catholic
chroniclers and modern scholars than it
is based in actual reality
instead the quote-unquote cathode church
is a specter created by the catholic
church at the time in their fear of
losing control and that what we know as
catherism was actually a manifestation
of social and political circumstances in
the region at the time rather than an
actual religious movement that can be
considered to have been unified into
anything resembling a church or holding
specific dualistic doctrines
the whole version of events that i have
presented in this episode can be
considered the traditional narrative it
is the version that scholars have
considered true for a couple of
centuries
but in the last few decades many
scholars have seriously challenged this
narrative as i hinted in the beginning
there are some serious problems with our
sources
they are almost exclusively either
hostile written by catholic chroniclers
or written at a later stage these
skeptical historians don't deny that the
crusades or inquisition took place of
course but the very idea that there was
anything like a european wide counter
church the topic quickly gets very
complicated once we take these
contemporary scholarly debates into
account if you want to know more about
this topic in particular and some of the
actual arguments against the existence
of catharism as we know it my good
friend dr justin sledge from the channel
esoterica is actually releasing a video
precisely on this topic today as a kind
of companion video to this one he will
be talking about arguments for and
against the existence of a cathode
church in medieval europe
and basically just go through this topic
a bit more in depth than what i have
done here so if you're interested in
knowing more about that topic in
particular as a continuation of the
discussions in this episode i highly
recommend you go check out that video
and his channel generally which you
should also definitely subscribe to it's
in my opinion one of the best
channels dealing with the academic study
of religion and philosophy and the
occult on all of youtube so definitely
go check that out for a more thorough
overview of the current scholarly
debates about this topic and regardless
of your stance about this problem in
particular there's no denying that the
catholics as they have become known to
us through history have played an
important role in the modern world as
well as is often the case
in the 20th and 21st century there has
been a kind of revival of the cather
doctrines of catholism the dualistic
ideas of catholism figures in the 20th
century like roche and simone whale
rekindled an interest in catholism as an
expression of an ancient secret
religious tradition that had been
continuously persecuted and oppressed
across history and there are even
communities today who actually
self-identify as catholics and practice
what they believe to be a continuous
tradition from this medieval church and
even all the way back to things like
gnosticism in this episode i have given
you a basic overview of the traditional
narrative of the so-called cathers a
fascinating religious community of
dualists in medieval france who if we
assume that they actually existed as
such
worried the catholic church to such a
degree that they brought on a full
crusade against them above all the story
about the catheters shows us how diverse
complex and vibrant any religious
tradition or historical context will
inevitably be
even in a context like medieval europe
which is often considered to be very
strict and rigid if you want to support
this channel you can do so monetarily by
becoming a patron on our patreon page
and i will leave a link to that in the
description special shout out to our new
saint wild osiris and to all of my
patrons for supporting this channel
but you can also simply leave a like
comment and subscribe to this channel
and i will see you next time
[Music]
you